>> OH!
WHAT'S UP, LOSER?
>> WHATCHA READING THERE?
>> A LITTLE COMIC BOOK.
>> WHAT'S A MANGA?
>> GIVE IT BACK!
>> OR WHAT?
YOU GOING CRY?
>> LITTLE BITCH IS GOING TO CRY?
>> HEY!
♪♪♪
>> LEAVE MY LITTLE BROTHER
ALONE.
SO HE'S NOT CAPTAIN OF THE
FOOTBALL TEAM, SO WHAT?
THIS GUY IS STILL COOL.
>> THANKS, JONAS.
>> SO WHAT IF HE'S NEVER KISSED
A GIRL.
BIG FREAKIN' DEAL!
THIS GUY PRACTICES KISSING ALL
THE TIME.
>> ALL THE TIME.
>> AND GUESS WHAT?
NEWS FLASH!
OUR MOM SAYS HE'S GETTING PRETTY
DAMN GOOD AT IT.
OH, YOU THINK HE'S WEIRD, RIGHT?
WHY?
BECAUSE HE SLEEPS IN OUR
PARENTS' BED WHEN HE'S SCARED?
>> SOMETIMES.
>> OR BECAUSE HE HAS TO WEAR
PRESCRIPTION CHARCOAL UNDERWEAR
FOR HIS MEDICAL GAS.
?
BUSTED!
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, I THINK HE'S
BRAVE.
>> YO, THIS BITCH?
BRAVE?
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
>> OKAY.
CAST YOUR MIND, IMAGINE THIS,
GOING INTO THE SCHOOL BATHROOM
AND TAKING A DUMP SO BAD THEY
HAD TO CANCEL CLASSES.
>> NO!
>> BUT STILL, SOMEHOW, HE SHOWS
UP TO SCHOOL THE NEXT DAY WITH
HIS HEAD HELD HIGH.
HE DID THAT.
>> THAT WAS YOU?
>> NO.
MAYBE.
>> YOU LOOK AT DAMIAN, AND ALL
YOU SEE IS A LONER, RIGHT?
A LOSER.
>> A KID WITH A LIST OF JOCKS
NAMES IN HIS WALLET.
>> THAT'S CONCERNING.
>> TO YOU, HE'S JUST A KID THAT
WON'T TAKE OFF HIS SHIRT IN GYM
CLASS, RIGHT?
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET OUT OF HERE.
>> BUT IF YOU HAD A BIRTHMARK
SHAPED LIKE A SWASTIKA YOU
WOULDN'T EITHER.
>> PLEASE STOP.
>> I'M WITH DAMIAN, JONAS.
MAYBE JUST STOP.
>> WHY?
SO YOU CAN MAKE FUN OF HIM AGAIN
ABOUT HIS INVERTED NIPPLES.
>> I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
>> OR HIS INVERTED FORE SKIN,
MAYBE.
>> OR THAT.
>> SEE, MAYBE IF YOUR FORE SKIN
GREW DOWN TOWARD THE BASE,
INSTEAD OF UP TOWARD THE TIP,
YOU WOULD HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
SYMPATHY FOR WHAT THIS DUDE HAS
BEEN THROUGH.
>> IT'S NOT THAT WEIRD.
>> 15 SURGERIES TO CORRECT IT.
>> MINOR.
>> CONSTANT CLEANING.
>> Q-TIPS, ALCOHOL.
>> ALCOHOL?
PARTY TIME.
>> STILL OUR MOM DOESN'T WANT TO
HAVE IT RE-DONE, WHY?
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T LOOK RIGHT.
>> EVERYONE'S A CRITIC.
>> WAIT, SORRY.
YOUR MOM?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE'S MY BROTHER AND HE'S COOL
ENOUGH FOR ME.
♪♪♪
♪
>> GO, DAMIAN.
GO.
>> OH!
>> AWW, HE DOOKIED HIMSELF.
>> HEY, DON'T THINK THAT IT WAS
YOUR BULLYING THAT MADE HIM DO
THAT, OKAY?
BECAUSE THAT HAS BEEN THERE ALL
DAY.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
♪♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]